how are you holding up well it's like  that movie Groundhog Day  it's 2019 I'm still under federal  investigation by you know two and a half  years the government reading all my  emails all my text messages listening to  all my phone calls and still they have  no evidence of Russian collusion  WikiLeaks collaboration or any other  crime it just seems to be never-ending I  was on Ellen Carlson last night and  talking about the impact on my family  and my business and so on it's you know  it's right up there with a pathological  examination I must tell you is one of  the great experiences of all time one  more gemandsam  catch up with full episodes and  interviews from celebrity guests anytime  on demand using the Sirius XM app